ce sont des images à peine croyable
celle de l'envahissement du capitole à
washington
hier en début d'après midi par des
centaines de supporters de donald trump
des supporters qui refusent la défaite
de leur leader et qui n'ont pas hésité à
forcer les portes du congrès américain
alors que les sénateurs étaient en
pleine séance pour valider
officiellement la victoire de joe biden
s'il ne fait aucun doute que donald
trump était heureux de ces mouvements de
foule à sa gloire face aux débordements
très grave de ses supporters
le président a décidé d'adresser sur
twitter un message d'apaisement à ses
fans c'était une élection complètement
frauduleuses il faut qu'on soit paisible
allait rentrer chez vous il faut dire
que le capital n'est pas un endroit
comme les autres il est l'antre du
pouvoir américain est censé être l'un
des endroits les mieux protégés au monde
ce qui explique la stupéfaction du
peuple américain façade et d'image digne
d'un coup d'état
une situation incroyable qui a nécessité
l'intervention des soldats de la garde
républicaine
bilan 4 morts et près de cinquante deux
interpellations ce soir on vous dit tout
sur cette soirée qui a chamboulé
l'amérique
alors on rigole cette émission n'était
rien vous a fait hermes c'est vrai et
françois sais c'est quoi ça le capital
c'est quoi l'équivalent ça veut dire
c'est l'assemblée nationale
et ça on imagine des gens qui rentrent à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale qui
se soit à la place des députés les
députés sont évacués et ces gens là sont
les emballe ya les militants du
président de la république c'est un peu
un truc un petit peu fou sur tout ce qui
se passe c'est que il ya quelques
semaines on se rappelle qu'il y avait
les antiracistes du black eyes matin il
était arrivé aussi pour manifester mais
pacifiquement et il y avait une rangée
de balle et c'était une horde de trois
rangées de militaires qui empêché
évidemment tout passage ça sans qu'ils
aient dit qu'ils avaient rentré là on va
voir les images qu'on vous a fait une
compile des images vous allez voir c'est
complètement fou imaginez la même chose
en france à l'assemblée nationale et
voici une question on doit vous prenez
pas ce qu'il y'a un truc qui m'a je me
suis dit un truc qui n est pas possible
qu'ils aient pu avancer autant alors
qu'il ya quelques semaines il y avait
trois rangées de militaires de rona
[Applaudissements]
à
ça alors oui moi je me suis produit une
question françois puisque donald trump
est ce qu'il n'aurait pas facilité
mine de rien oui l'on traité gaëlla il
aurait peut-être dit non voilà parce que
sinon il aurait pu il aurait pu être
stoppée mais là on va en fait tu ose
même pas dire ce qui en fait c'est sans
doute passé voilà c'est certes à dire
qu'en fait il ya quelque chose de sain
d'abord ils leur demandent d'y aller
chez eux ils sont à la maison blanche
ils sont pas loin de la maison blanche
et un discours de donald trump
il leur dit vous avez intérêt à être
féroce c'est ce qui leur dit on vous a
volé votre élection donc vous pouvez
être féroce et maison blanche au
capitole c'est assez loin donc ça veut
dire qu'on les voit arriver les gars
parce que c'est une majorité gars qui
arrive si on veut les arrêtés on peut
les arrêter
la mère de washington qui est démocrate
afro américaine veut qu'ils aient la
garde nationale et 10 faut absolument
arrêter ça et donald trump dit non on
n'en voit pas la garde nationale donc à
la base et c'est déjà qu' il n'y a pas
assez de sécurisation et là on voit il
n'avance pas vite un mot j'ai pensé
j'avais l'impression que c'était boxing
day des il avance comme granby il avait
inscrit hier ils sont là et là il est
tout seul alors qu'il ya 1700 policiers
au capitole alors les 6 7 ans les et son
je sais pas en tout cas là on en a vu
qu'un bon ce qui se passe c'est que
forcément il ya de la complicité alors
certains ont l'air gentil mais je sais
pas si on voit le davy crockett là qu'on
a vu et challans va le voir avant tout
c'est le symbole à lui il a l'air sympa
alors la réalité de ce qu'il est
vraiment sympa pour garder juste il a un
tatouage qui est trois triangles ces
trois triangles à c'est le symbole d'une
mythologie germanique
c'est sont les néo nazis on le voit
mieux là ces petits triangles et attend
néonazis ça veut dire antisémite
racistes etc donc il a l'air sympa il
l'est pas en fait là c'est la plupart
des gens qui sont là sont racistes east
suprémacistes sexistes et surtout ils
partagent un truc c'est qu'ils pensent
que l'élection a été volé ses acquis à 7
millions de voix d'écart ça 7 millions
de voix d'écart et ils se distinguent
ans a été volé les 7 millions c'est pas
où ils sont mais c'est même pas aux
états unis moi j'ai pris un taxi je suis
pas trois jours la personne me dit vous
êtes spécialiste des états unis vous
croyez au joe biden a été élu
sérieusement j'ai dit oui
non il n'a pas été élu c'est ici en fait
c'est une grosse farce
tu dis mais alors il faut penser que la
terre les platines maintenant elle est
légèrement incurvé donc là on est dans
les théories du combien sur sa théorie
du complot que partagent tous ces
américains
moi j'ai une question à vous poser après
maintenant sur joe biden il ya 77 ans
joe biden alors j'ai rien contre lui
mais ce qu aux etats unis
on n'aurait pas pu trouver quand même un
candidat un petit peu plus jeunes parce
qu'on dit il et voilà qu'il est par
défaut après il a il a l'intelligence de
dire que lui c'est un homme de la
transition
heureusement on est on est sûr que
quatre ans aux états unis quand même
quatre ans ça veut dire que lui il a dit
il passe la main à kamala harris kamala
harris a les jeunes première
afro-américaine à être vice présidence
que c'est vraiment lui le président ou
est-ce que c'est obama ont soumis
c'est un peu le troisième mandat de
barack obama est ce qu'on se dit c'est
vrai que barak s'est beaucoup impliqué
dans la campagne et ses vaccinations
vice président s est clair et lui mais
il a l'intelligence de dire ça moi j'ai
été le vice-président du premier
afro-américain président et je suis le
président de peut-être la prochaine
femmes présidentes la première femme
présidente l'intelligence et dire je
suis un homme de l'attrait dont six au
président des états unis
c'est barack obama c'est quand même lui
parce que parce qu'il ya quand même des
idées assez arrêté c'est celui qui va au
charbon quand il faut négocier aux états
unis faut toujours négocier avec le
congrès et barack obama quand il était
toujours un petit peu embarrassé il en
rit joe biden jo baier et très très
malin et là il va falloir négocier avec
la droite la gauche pour faire avancer
ses projets merci en tout cas françois
d'avoir été avec nous tous et le spécial
des états unis
y'a pas un burger qui se montre pas trop
ce que le sondage bah oui oui à 41 pour
son nom à 59% c'est possible une guerre
civile ou pas on a déjà eu une mais là
où penser que ça peut partir ça va être
quand l'intronisation de joe biden 20
janvier
donc la grande question c'est est ce que
donne un tram sera en train de faire un
golf en écosse s'est servi 20 ans et qui
fait c'est la première ministre
écossaise qui a dit non golf il sera
fermé on est encore vide 19 donc pas
question de faire un golf
donc est ce qui va être la voir se
passer le relais vous pensez que donald
trump peut refuser de lui passer le
relais et le laissé pour l'instant c'est
ce qui fait logiquement il devrait déjà
est en train de lui expliquer ses des
problèmes de sécurité nationale le 11
septembre 2001 pourquoi parce que al
gore il ya eu déjà un problème en 2000
il s'était pas passé le relais comme il
fallait on avait pris du retard et
patatras les attentats du 11 septembre
mais ça peut très bien se terminer
donald trump faut effectivement qui
donne un certain nombre d'éléments pour
que joe biden il puisse avancer sans
compter que il ya quand même trois cent
mille morts on le sait qu'on est passé
en moins de deux mois de 10 millions de
cas aux états unis à 20 millions 2,4
qu'ovide donc pendant qu'on s'amuse des
bêtises
ouais je serai bien il ya des américains
qui meurt